-Our next guest is one of the
best-selling authors
of all time.
His autobiography,
"James Patterson
by James Patterson:
The Stories of My Life"
is on sale now.
Please welcome back to the show
James Patterson.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back to the show!
-This is so cool.
I'm not usually up this late.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's a big deal
to have you
past the witching hour.
So, last time you were here
was with a book you co-wrote
with former
President Bill Clinton.
-Oh, yeah, I forgot about that.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Yeah.
You've written books
with Dolly Parton.
Is it nice to be out with the
-By myself, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-spotlight all to yourself?
-No, this is good. This is good.
I like it. I like it.
-You, obviously,
you write thrillers.
You come up
with thrilling titles,
the kind of title
that make people say,
"I've got to read this book."
-Are you suggesting that
that title isn't any good?
[ Laughter ]
It's clear.
-"James Patterson
by James Patterson"?
[ Laughter ]
-Here's a question I have
for you, though --
who the hell's the guy
on the cover?
-I was going to say
-[ Laughs ]
because I went and said hi
to you backstage
and then I saw this book
and I'm like,
"What's going on here?"
[ Laughter ]
-That's exactly what happens
to me.
I go to the mirror --
I go to the --
get up in the morning,
stumble into the bathroom,
and I look in the mirror
and I go,
"Oh, you again."
[ Laughter ]
-You talk about your, you know,
journey as a writer.
Obviously,
you could never have guessed
you would sell
over 400 million books
over the course of your career.
-Or 4,000.
-Any, yeah,
any number is a big number.
But you go to a bookstore early
in your career, when you're
about to find out your first --
you're going to have
your first hit book.
-Yeah.
-And a pretty interesting thing
happens when you see somebody
looking at it.
-Well, yeah, it was
on The Times Best-Seller List,
but I didn't believe it, so I
went into a local bookstore.
And what'll happen
with writers is,
if you pick up the book
and we're in the store,
we're watching you.
If you put it down,
it breaks our heart.
Not kidding.
[ Laughter ]
If you buy it, it makes our day.
So I'm watching this woman --
this is early in my career --
and she looks at it
and she looks at the back.
And then she walks
down the aisle and I said,
"This is the best. I want to go
hug this woman," you know?
She puts it on her bag.
She stole it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And all I'm going is,
"Does that count as a sale?"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Do you ever introduce yourself
to someone?
I mean,
you must see people reading
a James Patterson.
-I did, except, years ago,
I introduced myself
at a swimming pool to this guy.
I said, "How are you liking it?"
He goes, "It's [bleep]."
[ Laughter ]
That's -- It's terrible.
So I don't do it anymore.
[ Laughter ]
That was the last time.
You learn your lesson
when you get hit like that.
-Do you get recognized
as yourself now?
Certainly, this cover photo's
not going to help.
[ Laughter ]
-No, I know.
That's my hope.
[ Laughter ]
No, just last week,
my wife's out of town.
I go to this little
Italian restaurant
that we really like
and they say,
"Well, we'll fit you in."
So the waiter takes me
down a little aisle.
This woman pops up.
This is a true story.
Tragically.
[ Laughter ]
And she goes, "I know you.
You sold us
our insurance policy."
[ Laughter ]
This is true.
And then I go to my table
and I'm sitting there
and I get my appetizer
and the guy behind goes,
"Are you from Boston?"
And I turn around.
He goes,
"You're Tom Clancy!"
[ Laughter ]
I go, "No."
If I am,
we're all in big trouble
because he died nine years ago
and it's a horror movie.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, you write --
Your books are sort of known
for being very gripping --
short chapters.
-Like this one, gripping.
-Well, it is, though.
I mean, this reads --
this is so readable
and it has this, you know,
momentum within it that you
expect from one of your books.
Did you sit down to write it
like a thriller?
-You know, it was COVID and I,
you know,
we're thinking about life
and whatever and I just said,
"Let me just start writing down
some stories."
And I'm always conscious,
but I always try to pretend
there's somebody sitting
across from me,
I'm telling them a story,
I don't want them to get up
until I'm finished.
You could get up now.
It'd be funny.
[ Laughter ]
And that's kind of what I --
I mean, that's my, my deal.
-We were talking backstage.
I said I heard you speak
at an award show where you were
being honored and you --
-You sent me the nicest note.
-Well, you were very funny
and in a room where
-But that was then.
-Yeah, that was then.
[ Laughter ]
You also told a beautiful story
about your grandfather
and the way -- a thing
he told you about work.
-Yeah, well, he used to --
I'm a little kid
up in Newburgh, New York,
and it was a really
great thing for me.
I'm eight, nine, ten years old.
He would take me
on his delivery route
and he was a great guy
and it would go
over the Storm King Mountain
and he'd be singing
in a terrible voice.
He'd sing all these old songs,
"Oh, Susannah," whatever.
And he said, he said, "You know,
the secret is," he says,
"I hope, when you grow up,
that, when you go
over the mountain
to work in the morning,
you'll be singing."
And I do.
I just hope other people do.
I don't --
I don't work for a living.
I play for a living.
I suspect you do, too.
-I very much feel that way.
-Except when you get
a bad guest, and then --
[ Laughter ]
-You keep a basket of ideas
on your desk.
These are ideas for books?
-A very clever thing on a tile.
It says "Ideas," yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And do you just sort of
randomly reach in
when you feel like it's time?
-No, I don't randomly.
I'll just start going
through them and I'll go,
"What about, what about?"
And it's partly that
I feel excited about --
Sometimes you'll put something
away and, two years later,
you look at it and you go,
"I know where it goes now."
I didn't -- I didn't know --
I didn't know
where it was going.
-Do you still get excited,
having written all these books,
to see an idea for the first
and you go,
[ Snapping fingers ]
"Oh, now I know"?
-Yeah. Oh, yeah.
No, no, every day is --
Not every day,
but a lot of time --
Well, you know how it works.
I mean, just something.
Yeah, it's clicking.
"This is work.
I can make this work."
Or "this chapter work."
-I think it's exciting
because you just never know
when it's going to happen again.
-Yeah, well, there's that.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-We try not to think
about that too much.
-Absolutely.
-See, like with this thing,
I signed up
with Little Brown, so --
with the autobiography --
and I'm writing another one
when I'm 90
and another one when I'm 110.
-Oh, that's very smart.
-Yeah.
-You get that three-book deal.
-And I got the money upfront.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you for being here.
Congrats on the book.
-Thank you.
-Such a pleasure.
James Patterson, everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]
"James Patterson
by James Patterson"
is on sale now. We'll be right
back with more "Late Night."